OK.
Continuing to catch up about the press briefings.
Then we're going to move on to some other
stuff.
Unbelievable video for you today.
During yesterday's press briefing, Donald
Trump again started talking about masks and
95 respirator masks are in short supply.
The less protecting basic surgical masks are
also in short supply.
Sort search reply, short supply.
That's difficult to say.
So Trump floated the idea without any evidence
yesterday that he's skeptical about some of
the not the numbers that hospitals say they
need of these masks.
And he suggested without evidence that maybe
they are effectively falling off of the backs
of trucks, using other language to suggest
what are hospitals doing with these masks?
Are they stealing the masks?
So as an example, a health care CEO said during
yesterday's press briefing, you know, there's
a hospital we deal with.
They usually use 10 to 20 thousand masks a
month.
They now need 200 to 300000 masks per month.
And Trump's reaction was, are some going out
the back door?
Are these being stolen? Trump was confused
about why so many masks were being used for
years, 10 to 20000 masks.
OK.
It's a New York hospital, very packed all
the time.
How do you go from 10 to 20 to 300000, 10
to 20000 masks to 300000, even though this
is different?
Something's going on.
And you want to look into it as reporters
wear the mask on or are they going out the
back door?
How do you go from 10000 to 300000?
And we have that in a lot of different places.
So somebody should probably look into that,
because I just don't see from a practical
standpoint how that's possible to go from
that to that.
And we have that happening in numerous places.
Donald Trump is incredulous about the increase.
He says something must be going on there.
Yes.
What's going on is coronavirus.
They need the masks.
They're using the masks.
Every time you do one Corona virus test that
uses a mask.
New York has 60000 cases.
That's 60000 masks to do those tests.
Every time you interact with a patient in
the E.R., that's a mask.
The nurse, the doctor, the person who checks
you into the hospital, the X-ray tech is likely
using a mask at this point in time.
Its masks every time.
And Trump is suggesting maybe there is not
really a shortage, meaning he did nothing
wrong.
Remember, all of this is meant to say he did
nothing wrong.
Someone else did something wrong.
Maybe hospitals are stealing masks, which
shifts the blame from him once again to somebody
else.
Look at how simple the math is, though.
Imagine a hospital with a couple hundred nurses
and a couple hundred covered patients per
day.
You're using the masks as directed magic in
one day.
You know, one hundred of those couple hundred
nurses that the hospital may have are working
or whatever.
Hundred patients, hundred nurses.
Three interactions per day, 30 days.
That's a million masks right there.
Now, of course, that's an overestimate.
They're rationing the masks.
They probably aren't.
You know, the full slate of nurses isn't working
every day.
There's shifts, there's rotation.
Okay.
But you get the idea.
300000 masks is very realistic.
It would even sound low considering that you've
got hospitals that are huge, that have other
things going on.
You do an appendectomy that comes in that
needs to be done.
You've got an anesthesiologist and a surgeon
and a nurse.
That's five masks right there.
But Trump's instinct is it can't possibly
be that I screwed up.
It can't possibly be that I failed to get
anybody masks.
Maybe masks are falling off the back of the
truck.
In other words, being stolen by workers.
It's not just incredibly disgusting and immoral,
but it is another sign of what Dr. Justin
Frank has been telling us.
The inability to ever take responsibility,
the inability to ever say I may have been
slow on something is part of the slate of
disorders that Dr. Justin Frank and many other
mental health professionals believe Donald
Trump is suffering from.
We're going to get to that later.
In the meantime, if you're not following me
on Instagram, I've been keeping my Instagram
light and I have some very funny.
I have a mattress face plant video on my Instagram
that is distracting people for like 10 seconds
from the crisis we're dealing with.
Check it out.
It's on my Instagram at David Pakman.
Follow the show on Instagram while you're
there at David Pakman.
Coming up next, is the virus a germ or what
Trump still does?